hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to learn how
to convert between three different
temperature scales
these are Fahrenheit Celsius and Kelvin
first of all let's talk about
temperature how hot or cold one object
is relative to another is what we know
of as temperature this means that all
temperatures are relative so they're
being compared to something else you can
think of it like this temperature
indicates heat flow and specifically
heat flow from a hotter object to a
cooler object so for example if you
accidentally place your hand on an oven
burner that's very very hot that
transfers a lot of heat a lot of heat
energy from the burner into your hand
and that's what you feel is the
difference with how hot the burner is
now let's talk about those three
different temperature scales there's
Fahrenheit so degrees Fahrenheit in our
calculations we will abbreviate it as TF
there's also degrees Celsius which will
abbreviate in our calculations as TC and
there's also Kelvin Kelvin does not have
a degree symbol it's simply K and in our
calculations we'll call it TK so now
let's talk about the calculations
themselves how do you convert from one
temperature scale to another to convert
from Celsius to Fahrenheit you use this
equation that is the temperature in
Fahrenheit is equal to one point eight
times the temperature in Celsius plus 32
let's do an example let's say that we
want to convert from 10 degrees Celsius
to Fahrenheit well this would be one
point eight times 10 degrees so
yes plus 32 and this is going to equal
1.8 times 10 is 18 plus 32 50 degrees
Fahrenheit so 10 degrees Celsius is
equal to 50 degrees Fahrenheit the
calculation to get from Celsius to
Kelvin is a little easier it's just the
temperature in Celsius plus 273.15 so
for example if we start with that 10
degrees Celsius again temperature in
Kelvin is the 10 degrees Celsius plus
273.15 which equals 283 point 15 Kelvin
you may have heard of something called
absolute zero absolute zero is equal to
zero Kelvin it is the coldest possible
temperature and it only occurs when all
of the atoms and molecules have
completely stopped moving there is no
place on earth that is as cold as
absolute zero every place on earth is
still warm enough for there to be some
atoms and molecules that are able to
vibrate still have the energy to vibrate
even outer space is slightly warmer than
absolute zero now let's briefly talk
about how to get from Fahrenheit to
Celsius that is if you were given
Fahrenheit and asked to convert to
Celsius you could do that simply by
rearranging this equation if you're
interested in learning how to solve
equations like that see my video called
solving equations but basically it has
to do with isolating the variable that
you need so if we had the temperature in
Fahrenheit we wanted to solve the
temperature in Celsius we would simply
rearrange this equation by subtracting
32 from each side and then dividing by
1.8 this means that
BC equals TF minus 32 divided by 1.8 if
you'd like to see how to go through the
steps to get from this one to this one
again see that video on solving
equations but that is it for today
thanks for watching biology professor